yvan cournoyer est mort le 11 novembre
2010 est à 54 ans il a choisi l'aide
médicale à mourir pour éviter que la
maladie dans sl à lui arrache sa dignité
papa de la ta place de quelqu'un qui
s'en vont vers la marque alice début mai
la journée plus l'eau c'est comme les
mythes qu'à l'amour et c'est comme
nouveau jantes alu phares la conjointe
d'yvon a accepté de nous confier comment
elle a vécu les derniers moments avec
son amoureux et ce qu'elle a ressenti
après son départ le 15 les aider à
s'installer à s'installer dans son lit
mais dit ça fait tellement longtemps
chaque instant moment l'eau c'est ce qui
m'a dit très clairement ce serait s'est
couché je ne suis chaque côté de lui
l'autre légende repasser mon grand père
le 18 novembre
moi je partis le 19 décembre que gt tour
10 pendant walo tf1 tout et libye
chauvin bordeaux après le départ d'yvon
chantal épuisé il ad rejoindre sa mère
au mexique fait partie chrome os
pourrait aller soigner un enfant mais
cache est revenue et je me disais je
sais qu'un jour année la joie de jouer
dans le nom réalité11 pas facile
[Musique]
c'est un coffre
personnes choisissent c'est son départ
choisi le lieu choisi leur en 2016
emmanuel dufour a accompagné son grand
père atteint d'un cancer au cerveau
c'était preto la loi est passée on était
comment les premiers on connaissait
personne autour de nous expliqué qu'elle
évitera par le dessin la bande dessinée
et la documenter cette nouvelle réalité
je penche été chanceuse parce que pour
faciliter monde a échappé le médium du
dessin en publiant sa bande dessinée
emmanuel réaliser à quel point les
proches qui vivent de près la médicale à
mourir sont souvent démunis non par mois
je reçois des courriels de gens qui ne
faisaient que la bande dessinée leur a
fait du bien parce que ça lui a permis
justement de revivre certains éléments
c'est certain point certains flash et
plusieurs personnes m'ont demandé à ce
que tu en connais des délais et des
groupes de soutien où on peut aller
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et j'avais
chercher moi-même pour ma grand mère à
l'époque et j'en avais pas trouvé pas de
trouver de ressources spécialisées et
adaptés à cette nouvelle réalité
ses dessins et relate la vie la maladie
et les dernières heures de son grand
père son texte évoque les minutes qui
s'envole la faim qui approche à grands
pas on est en train de fouiller dans les
bois de souvenirs de photos de discuter
avec lui
le sauna la porte c'est le médecin
jusque là à partir de là le cerveau
celui-ci placé dans mon corps tout cas
moi je sais que ça a été comme le chèque
le plus grand c'est c'est justement
c'est ce monde surréel
est-ce qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que il ya
énormément de souffrance comment allez
vous la docteur nathalie than fait
partie des premiers médecins qui ont
accepté d'administrer les médicale à
mourir ça nous libère un peu des limites
qu'on avait avant pour le soulagement
des souffrances qui sont énormes
souvent les patients sont très souffrant
puis ils veulent ils veulent rapidement
avoir le soin mais même les médecins
doivent apprendre à s'adapter à cette
nouvelle réalité
c'est clair que c'est quelque chose qui
vient nous chercher à tous les niveaux
il ya tellement d'émotion qu'il faut
quand même bien les gérer et puis c'est
important de bien les gérer en tant que
médecin parce qu'il faut qu'on demeure
fonctionnel il faut qu'on soit capable
de donner ce soin love la bonne façon
moi je dis toujours c'est de l'année de
le laisser partir aussi si la tristesse
est encore immense plus de deux ans plus
tard chantal phare reste fière du
courage dont a fait preuve ils vont
jusqu'à la fin j'ai tout tenté d'accord
avec son choix
en partant des théâtres s'endormait puis
elle dit je vais prendre soin des
plantes sont visés
pas juste se mettent aussi
chantal phare se dit sereine parce que
son amoureux est parti comme il le
souhaitait en toute dignité
[Musique]